regresar derrotados después de exponer
sus vidas en el mar estos haitianos
huyeron en un bote hacia Estados Unidos
pero fueron interceptados y devueltos a
Puerto Príncipe
intentamos salir de Haití para otro país
pero lastimosamente el clima no nos
ayudó y fuimos deportados yo soy una
haitiano y me gustaría vivir en mi país
pero la situación me lo impide
[Música]
en este país no hay trabajo
está muy mal
vamos a pensar en salir de nuevo
Aquí no hay trabajo y hay problemas de
seguridad
desorientados y sin un destino claro lo
único que saben estos hombres y mujeres
es que tendrán que enfrentarse de nuevo
a la dura realidad de Haití
Yes humedez René también se iría Si
tuviera oportunidad esta madre soltera
vive en este cuarto de 16 metros
cuadrados con sus tres hijos y otras dos
personas Ella es una desplazada interna
porque tuvo que huir de su barrio a
causa de la violencia de la ciudad
ayer hablé con mi hermano mayor me dijo
que estaba angustiado cuando dormía
porque disparan entran a las casas de la
gente y no había podido dormir en la
noche
uno no vive realmente no tenemos vida
yesumene trabaja como empleada doméstica
y apenas puede alimentar a sus hijos
se preocupa por el futuro de su familia
A pesar de sentirse más segura en este
nuevo vecindario
a los niños les gustaba Donde vivíamos
antes
les gustaba mucho pero no sé si al
crecer se quieran ir del país No sé no
veo cuál puede hacer Su futuro
[Música]
hoy tengo arroz blanco arroz con Frijol
salsa de frijoles y legumbres
Daddy también es madre soltera prepara y
vende comida en la calle su lucha en un
país donde escasean los empleos es
mantener su negocio a flote confiesa que
está al borde de la quiebra
es muy complicado invertir en un
comercio
por ejemplo Este arroz no lo conseguimos
fácil y en este momento está muy caro
nadie tiene la capacidad de consumo ni
en lo más básico
preparó la comida
pero muy poca gente viene a comprar
vendo muy poco
en Haití el salario mínimo es de unos
100 dólares al mes y la inflación
alcanzó el 47% en 2022 casi la mitad del
país sufre inseguridad alimentaria aguda
según el programa mundial de alimentos
de las Naciones Unidas
llamad es uno de los empresarios que
importa alimentos para surtir al país y
emplea a unas 600 personas este Franco
marroquí Lleva más de 30 años en la isla
y ha tenido que adaptarse a la crisis la
mayor parte de su negocio es la
importación de pollo y los trae más
baratos para que la gente pueda comprar
de igual manera Tiene una línea más fina
para varios restaurantes de su propiedad
en Puerto Príncipe Aquí tienen salmón
ahumado que viene de Noruega
y Estos son filetes de salmón fresco que
servimos en nuestro restaurantes
denuncia Bono tú no ves todo
este empresario es pesimista sobre el
futuro económico el abastecimiento de
gasolina la corrupción aduanera y la
inseguridad son los principales
problemas a los que según él tiene que
hacer frente
no hay empresas que quieran venir a
invertir en Haití solamente están las
empresas que ya están establecidas acá
que intentan sobrevivir y que pagan sus
gastos
pero eso es todo a nivel de alimentación
pase lo que pase siempre hay que darle
comida a la gente
Yamaha ya está pensando en su retiro
cada vez es más complicado para él tener
una vida normal y poder manejar su
negocio
tenemos quizás 30 camiones Pero tenemos
problemas con ellos policía debe
explotarlos
desde hace unos meses vive dentro de su
almacén porque prefiere evitar cualquier
desplazamiento fuera de la fortaleza que
construyó aquí pueden ver el muro Este
muro está alrededor de toda la propiedad
sí tengo personas de seguridad que están
armadas como lo pueden ver seguridad con
armas de noche y de día y tengo unos
perros de ataque que dejó salir en la
noche Hay días considerado como uno de
los países más peligrosos del mundo unas
600 mil armas legales e ilegales
circulan en esta nación de menos de 12
millones de habitantes un centenar de
bandas se afianzan día tras día en la
capital se enfrentan a una policía
frágil y mal equipado
en la última semana de enero de 2023 14
funcionarios murieron en diversos
enfrentamientos un comisario de la
Policía Nacional sin revelar su
identidad nos Comenta sobre las
precarias condiciones con las que
trabajan los agentes
hay territorios donde no podemos entrar
sin un carro blindado
necesitamos los medios equipos y
vehículos que nos permitan no perder
otras zonas de la ciudad que son
actualmente libres de pandillas
nadie duda de que algunos policías
tienen vínculos con las bandas pero
reina la ley del silencio
y la población civil sigue siendo la
principal víctima de esta guerra
territorial
este hospital de la organización médico
Sin fronteras está especializado en
traumatología y quemaduras
el hombre que llegó esta mañana fue
atacado con un machete cuando salía de
su casa los motivos del ataque no están
claros como suele ser el Común
denominador
es un caso de heridas por arma blanca en
la parte del miembro superior izquierdo
con noción de flagelación
cirujano para él no hay necesidad de
operarlo pero habrá que cerrar las
heridas profundas en tres años de
servicio en ese hospital El doctor ha
visto todo tipo de pacientes y dramas a
priori la violencia toca a todo el mundo
con este paciente es un caso bastante
excepcional
con bastante frecuencia son personas que
viven en zonas en las que hay conflictos
entre dos pandillas rivales
son los daños colaterales o miembros de
las pandillas que llegan en algunos
casos el hospital También recibe
accidentes de tráfico o Víctimas de
caídas sin embargo las heridas de bala
ocupan el 70% de su actividad la
situación parece haber empeorado en los
últimos meses antes los impactos de bala
eran sobre todo con balas de pequeños
calibres
en este caso con menos velocidad
hoy en día hay una tendencia al aumento
ya que los pacientes que recibimos y que
son impactados por bala vienen heridos
con municiones de Gran calibre que dejan
heridas importantes con las que la
recuperación toma más tiempo que los
casos de antes
en la sala de hospitalización desde hace
cuatro días se encuentra un hombre
víctima de la violencia de bandas
recientemente las pandillas instalaron
en su barrio un retén ante la situación
intentó huir de su casa y lo
interceptaron se salvó de las balas pero
no de una fractura en sus piernas
empezaron a interrogarme dos de los
bandidos uno de ellos me dijo le voy a
disparar
y el otro me dijo escala el muro
entonces decidí subir el muro
apenas alcance la cima uno de ellos me
dijo si usted no quiere que le dispare
tiene que tirarse del otro lado
cuando salte caí en un abismo
inimaginable solamente escuché que se me
partieron las dos piernas
la violencia de estas bandas parece no
tener límites ahora controlan más del
60% del territorio de la capital
desde la sede de la ong el jefe de
misión de médicos Sin fronteras reconoce
que esta rápida expansión de los grupos
armados que está perturbando el
funcionamiento de sus hospitales
Raúl Pierre Luis es el hospital donde
médicos Sin fronteras ya no presta apoyo
después de que la semana pasada unos
hombres armados entraron para sacar un
paciente y ejecutarlo fuera del hospital
en este mapa se puede ver en rojo las
zonas de la ciudad bajo control de las
pandillas y en blanco no hay presencia
fuerte de ellas por ahora estos fueron
los lugares por donde pudimos
desplazarnos para la realización de este
reportaje
este de martizo
esta mañana el ambiente Está pesado en
el estudio de la radio Quisqueya donde
el escritor Leonel Trujillo presenta un
programa semanal sobre la vida cultural
del país
Qué opinan del país donde estamos
viviendo
personalmente ocurrió El secuestro de mi
mejor amigo que fue liberado ayer a
cambio de una importante suma de dinero
y esta mañana unos bandidos armados
entraron en una escuela en tomasan y han
pedido plata los secuestros forman parte
de la cotidianidad de Puerto Príncipe es
el modus operandi que han usado los
grupos delictivos para financiarse y
conseguir armas entre otras cosas cada
día raptan al menos dos o tres Rehenes
Cómo vive una mujer en el contexto
artístico tomando en cuenta el contexto
sociopolítico abominable y teniendo en
cuenta todos los sistemas de dominación
que se perpetúan Leonel y sus invitadas
debaten este día sobre el lugar de la
mujer en el mundo artístico haitiano
se trata de un doble problema en un país
donde la vida cultural casi ha
desaparecido y donde el número de
agresiones contra las mujeres no deja de
aumentar
es fundamental tener este tipo de
emisiones Porque aquí es donde circula
en realidad el discurso haitiano de lo
que queremos hacer con este país
tenemos este gobierno que cuesta
llamarlo gobierno que no tiene ninguna
legitimidad y sin poder convencer a
nadie en Haití
necesita una fuerza extranjera para
legitimar su existencia
el gobierno del que habla Leonel es el
de Ariel que fue nombrado Primer
Ministro por el presidente juvenil mois
dos días antes de su asesinato en julio
de 2021 y cuya administración gobierna
desde entonces el rey sufre un profundo
déficit de popularidad en su país se le
acusa de estar a sueldo de Estados
Unidos y de ser partidario de una
intervención extranjera que pospondría
la celebración de nuevas elecciones una
forma de conservar el poder Jean grenell
antiguo senador creó su propio partido
político hace dos años y denuncia la
desaparición de la vida política en la
isla las últimas elecciones celebradas
se remontan a 2016 y desde principios de
enero ya no cuenta con ningún
representante de electo nacional ni
local hoy en día estamos obligados a ser
dirigidos políticamente por un gobierno
de facto
un gobierno golpeado por un déficit de
legitimidad y de legalidad
ninguna institución funciona actualmente
mientras la inseguridad continúe esto
ayuda a este gobierno para tener
elecciones creíbles la primera urgencia
que debemos atender es la problemática
de la seguridad
nos reunimos de nuevo con Leonel
Trujillo que todos los jueves por la
tarde dirijo un taller de escritura en
donde los participantes debaten sobre
literatura y lo que viven a diario
vivimos en Haití en la realidad haitiana
esta realidad que es algo inaceptable
y vivimos con el sueño de poder
cambiarla
pero muchas no quieren esperar a que
este sueño se haga realidad las oficinas
de inmigración están desbordadas con
cientos de ciudadanos que intentan
obtener pasaportes desde que el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
incluyera los haitianos en un programa
para entrar legalmente a Estados Unidos
algunos no tienen la esperanza de que el
país mejore como Este joven que accedió
a hablar con La Cara Oculta
allí es el infierno
donde se encuentra es una célula
delincuentes
y es como si nosotros estuviéramos
atrapados en una prisión no podemos
hacer nada pero nosotros no necesitamos
un ejército ni un grupo de tanques ni
Marines que vengan acá no no nosotros no
queremos ese desorden
huir o quedarse habrá una intervención
extranjera se organizarán elecciones el
futuro nunca ha sido tan incierto en
Haití mientras Espera que mejore el
panorama estos jóvenes disfrutan de una
tarde alquilando una bicicleta y
paseando por un parque un momento
suspendido en medio del caos